on a very busy monday morning and we are  still following the  developing stories two of them across  the valley metro police investigating  two  early morning homicides metro says the  first happened on sahara near paradise  the bottom of your screen  the second on valley view at meadows  lane near the meadows mall and springs  preserve and that is where our crew has  just gotten to the scene here you see a  live picture  this is from valley view and meadows  lane we are waiting for a press  conference from metro police homicide  detectives to get some details on this  case and the other one over on sahara  we'll have more details all throughout  good day las vegas and cbs this morning